encouragement from a colleague and tanda
no bazzill needs all the kindness he can
get the policeman just happened to be at
Ground Zero when the militants attacked
the mental trauma far more severe than
his physical wounds below comas happily
the cannon fire took us by surprise we
were totally unprepared before I could
figure out what was going on a bullet
hit me in the arm ravine below as you
see LeBron did you see when it was over
at least 29 people were dead including
foreigners from 18 countries about 60
patients are treated in this over
crowded Hospital alone people are still
in shock but many already start asking
now how bikina Faso can prevent further
attacks investigations continue at the
scene of the terrorist attack the new
government has been in power for just a
few weeks president ROC Mark Christian
Kubrick has offered words of support for
citizens of the capital telling them we
refused to hang our heads journalist
Stephen Kim Tory says the assault will
test the mettle of the new president and
his government I'm not saying it's
impossible for the government in Burkina
Faso to stop terrorism but with our
limited resources it will be very
difficult the policemen bazoo believes
militants could strike again at any time
he's hoping for a speedy recovery and to
get back on the streets as soon as
possible